for me great content comes from the
heart or the brain someone just asked me
what kind of content do you find does
the best my answer in my Discord was the
one that comes from the heart or the one
that comes from the brain you were
either winning on emotional truths or
intellectual truths things that you
really believe in or have real passion
for or that you really know so much
of what garyvee has won on in my opinion
is the vision I love is that I know and
I've got both but when I break off into
you know maybe I'm less passionate about
it but I'm speaking to it or I'm
passionate and it's more like sports
stuff or blueberries or stuff of that
and I don't know as much about it those
work so